how many of you are familiar with Star
Wars enough good I'm building my
communications Death Star I have 2,000
employees around the globe I'm the
emperor and with my communications Death
Star I can point it at anything I want 7
years ago I pointed it at an app we
incubated at Boehner called resi and
that was highly successful and we sold
that to AMX 3 years later I pointed my
death star at empathy wines a direct
consumer wine brand and we sold at to
consolation a couple years ago I made a
really big b and I pointed my death star
and a ton of Stormtroopers and even a
couple of Darth Vaders to something
called V friends which is my Pokemon
Sesame Street intellectual property so
they may know how to make great content
ESPN the Jazz everybody there's a lot of
talented storytellers the problem is
every Storyteller that has been trained
for the last 30 years was not trained in
having to think about the distribution
the distribution was just a screen today
there's not a single time that I post
produce video that I'm recording that
I'm not thinking about how the algorithm
works it's because I'm watching I'm day
trading attention this is a skill of day
trading all of Pop Culture distribution
creative variables I'm pretty excited to
be here and I'm ready to dive in my man
let's let's go well so first of all um
so much to talk about uh how many of you
are working in a business or part of a
tech company raise your hand I just want
to see I just want to see okay so I
think to to start Gary let's you and I
have had a lot of conversations over the
years around the future marketing the
future of media um and and I want to
it's not going to be one question it's
going to be a couple but I want to
unpack what's your scene from a brand
marketing standpoint um from a marketing
standpoint and we're just going to Rift
for a second because um I think we're
watching a lot of transformation I we
just launched Jazz plus about an hour
ago where everyone can now between K
Jazz hold on hold on that was a [__]
clap let's clap it up for jazz
club we went from 1.2 million people to
3.2 million people that can now watch
games we're going into Idaho Wyoming and
Washington we basically gone from
basically 1.2 to 5 million people are
going to have access to our our Jazz
Network and it's basically a curated
experience to shift the model from
contract to eyeball
and we've talked a lot about
how that is an art and they're actually
making that art now a science and I
think it's very very relevant for every
single person here every parent here who
has kids who are on social media who are
who are at the intersection of
Storytelling of business it's a lot to
unpack y but that's what everyone in
Utah needs to hear because very few
people have done it as well as you thank
you so I think you it's interesting I
caught the last few minutes of Jimmy
right before we came on and if you
notice what he said about hey we're
making content on social and we're
realizing how that's affecting our owned
and operated what he's referring to is
something that I think about and I call
day trading attention so day trading
attention day trading attention so if
we're leaving with something it's this
phrase trading attention and when I come
to a conference like this and I have so
many different people here in different
parts of their lives some people work at
companies and have a side hustle they
sit on a nonprofit board they sit on uh
an education board they they are the
leader of a company what what I love
about the concept that I'm about to talk
about which is how do you not waste a
single dollar or in Reverse how do you
spend every dollar to maximize the thing
that you want to happen right the one
thing that I can guarantee connects
everyone here is there's things things
they'd like to happen in life incl it
might be a stay-at home parent and they
want their kid to have a happy life it's
all based on
communication the one thing We're All
Tied by here is the ability to
communicate and that becomes an
incredible variable of what happens all
of our political views all of our
biggest standards how we see the world
it's all been story told To Us by
parents by outside forces this is the
thing I've always been fascinated by
I know some of you know who I am I know
a lot of you don't I was born in the
Soviet Union in the USSR I came to the
US when I was three and grew up in the
80s in America so I was immediately
fascinated by the Cold War and was
paying attention to how people did
messaging I was interested long before
we started talking about it in America
about what the media was doing I was
also interested in Word of Mouth and I
was always a businessman when I sold
lemonade when I was seven I spent more
time on making signs and putting them up
on the right pole I would think about
how sick I was I was seven and I would
walk around Edison New Jersey with a
sign and I thought it was interesting
and cool to sit down on a hill at a
cross-section and watch cars driving by
to try to figure out which tree or post
or pole was the best one to put my
lemonade stand 20 cents for limit e so
I've been chasing attention my whole
life and what I know is as we sit here
today there's an extraordinary amount of
money being wasted by internal teams by
external agencies by the production of
videos pictures and written word by the
media spend that you spend on Google and
Facebook and Tik Tok and television and
outdoor and print and badges on you can
steal an NBA badge or you can overpay
pay for it there is no guaranteed deal
the best deal in day trading attention
aka the best ad in America today is the
Super Bowl spot it's the best ad the
problem is even though the 7 or $8
million for 30 seconds that will get you
110 American million Americans to
consume it even though that's the best
ad if you screw up the 30C video it's
not the best so you have this game of
spending media dollars to get attention
and then you have the creative the video
the picture the audio the written word
as the variable if you're going to sell
sneakers ticket sales streaming B2B
contracts help your sales team if you're
a SAS business this is the biggest
conversation from ESPN to a single
person entrepreneur looking to sell
chocolate next week and I think the
majority of the people in this room are
grossly underestimating the platforms
that dominate the attention of our
society and the majority of them are are
sitting on this thing right here now of
course streaming has incredible amounts
of attention and of course there's other
variables I mean I like running videos
at gas station pumps because people
consume them against the price I think
sometimes buying outdoor Billboards is a
good deal but this goes to the framework
that I want everyone here to take away
day trading attention meaning you're
doing it every day you're day trading
you don't just blindly say that Google
AdWords work you have to change the
creative on your Google AdWords against
emerging Trends nobody was searching the
combo of Kelsey and Taylor Swift a month
ago and now they are what does that mean
if anything and there's 700,000 other
things going on in culture right this
nanc and most people are punting
marketing because they don't understand
it which is why we have those classic
phrases of I'm wasting 50% of my money I
just don't know what 50% and I don't
believe it has to be that way but I
don't believe anyone in this Stadium but
by the way probably including me takes
it serious enough CU it is the most
controllable variable to create the
outcome that you want so day trting
attention would be this concept that I
just want to thank the guy who whistled
thank you for
that there was a bunch of other who
can't wh but they tried
to so day trading attention is this
concept that the old world or scene one
would be you place a marketing camp
campaign and you leave and you go focus
on what it is to the new world which is
scene to you've got it in it every
minute every single thing matters every
channel matters and it's this living
breathing thing and those organizations
who do the best at it are the ones that
are going to win
period period and and look marketing is
the offense if you stuck at defense I
really don't want to talk football right
now cuz I'm super [__] pissed come
on S this is actually you said we weren
going I the Jets thing is really a
problem right now but anyway the look
what I want to be careful here cuz I
want everybody here to the people that
are best in the world on what we just
talked about do I think they're going to
win they're going to win on the offense
they're going to acquire the most
customers you everybody here knows you
could screw up the business a million
ways that has nothing to do with how
much revenue you bring in so yes do I
think the people in this room and
actually by making noise how many people
are familiar with me and the things I
talked
about and that and I know this is a very
very nice place so don't feel bashful
but I'm just trying to understand
something real quick please make equal
amount of noise cuz I know you're going
to be nice to me but don't be nice to me
equal amount of noise if you don't know
me at
all I feel pretty my self-esteem isn't
good that was good that was good that
was
like no 73 that felt good anyway
especially for the 30 40% that don't
know and and honestly weirdly enough
maybe even more for the 60 to 70% that
do know please make this the time even
if you're one of those people that's
heard this from me 99 times and
definitely if you've never heard this
from me please listen to me everything
on
Earth is based on communication
everything everything like it's it's way
bigger than you think and I can't
believe in 2023 heading into 2024 how
many of you here do not take social
media serious it has the far majority of
our country's attention the world's
attention on it and let me say this nice
and slow right this is business
101 it's
free let me just the distribution is
free of course you can run ads on it and
of course it costs money to make a video
or things of that nature but you're not
calling the Jazz for sponsorship and
Ryan's like yeah no problem put your
patch on my jersey it's free you can't
get a newspaper ad for free Google is
not free you can't do a commercial for
free radio ads are not free for the
first time distribution is potentially
free and for the real players in this
room and this is a big one Ry for the
real players in this room you know that
we've gone through a massive
transformation in social media in the
last 24 months which I refer to as the
Tik tock ofic of social media and what
that means is the following I
invested 17 years ago in three companies
they were the first three companies I
invested in they were called Facebook
Twitter and
Tumblr so that means that I made a lot
of money but it also means something
important for this point when I invested
in Tumblr which was the third of those
three Investments back in 2006 I called
my brother AJ and I said you know
obviously I just invested in Facebook
and Twitter 6 months earlier 3 months
earlier and I called AJ I had this
meeting with David karp the founder of
Tumblr which was a New York based tech
company which was unusual and I called
AJ and I said bro I just invested in the
biggest one of them all Tumblr will be
bigger than Facebook and Twitter first
thank God I did not make that
video second let me tell you why I said
it I said it because the mistake I made
was I didn't take into consideration at
the time the jockey not the horse
obviously EV Williams and Jack were more
capable operators Mark Zuckerberg was a
more capable operator than David karp
now David KP still sold Tumblr for a
billion dollars years ago when a billion
was like 50 billion now right so it was
still a monster exit but let me tell you
why I thought Tumblr was going to be the
biggest Facebook and Twitter what I
explained to AJ on that call which I
actually wish I did record so I could
show it to you now and tell you how long
I've been waiting for the tiktock
ification of
social Facebook and Twitter you followed
people
it was your social graph and it worked
like email marketing we would all try to
amass as many followers and a percentage
of our followers would open like open
rates right get a million followers
27,000 to 250,000 would see it it worked
like email I understood that I built my
daddy's wine business on email I
understood Tumblr was doing something
different you were following your
interests and I I'm going to you can
tell them right here it is it's about to
come I don't you see it yeah I see them
okay the reason I just got
goosebumps is cuz I remember what I felt
once I understood what Tumblr was doing
which was our interests are more
powerful than the people we follow as a
matter of fact all of our friends are
almost solely based on our interest we
became friends on aligned interests so I
fell in love with Tumblr and so for the
people that follow me the most and I've
got some friends in the front that I
know do you remember 7 years ago I went
crazy on musically
the reason and everybody was like all
right this is the time Gary actually
lost his mind why is an app that has
13-year-old girls dancing on it why is
he yelling about this because I saw the
interest graph come back and I knew that
it started with 14-year-old girls but we
would all eventually be there cuz it's
the most powerful thing now Instagram
Facebook YouTube shorts snapis Discovery
Twitter all of the platforms now are
showing you higher percentage and I
believe Tik Tok included is not showing
us enough of it I think they should be
pot committed to just showing us what we
want to consume cuz that's how the world
actually works and I think the future
Battle of who's going to win this battle
of these four or five companies is which
algorithm goes all the way to just
showing us what we want to be seeing
instead of random stuff and so for this
is a long-winded setup for something I
want everyone to hear for the first time
ever in the history of marketing
the content creates the
distribution the way every other
platform for 100 years has worked from
Radio to billboard to direct mail to
television to the whole internet was you
made a picture or video and then you
paid money to try to get in front of
people for the first time ever the and
it did not matter how good your video or
picture was if you made a shitty
commercial NBC did not give you their
money back they took it and it ran for
the first time ever the
quality of the creative creates the
distribution there are people in this
room who do not have a Tik Tok account
who tomorrow can open one have zero
followers and if they make a quality
piece of creative that is interesting to
the masses could have a million people
see it this is unprecedented this
Matter's big and here's where it becomes
Atomic the OTS and fast channels and
streaming services are building their ad
product more like that than like
television and so we are in a crash
course in the next 5 to 7 years where
every ad above the line as they call it
television and all of social will be now
in a place where the creative is a
variable to the success greater than
we've ever seen and the practitioners I
sit here today as a man who knows the
difference between putting a p the same
picture on LinkedIn Facebook Twitter
Youtube Youtube Shorts Facebook reals
Facebook Main feed TW like all these
platforms I know the difference of what
it needs to look like what the first 3
seconds need to look like what the title
needs to look like what time to post it
how much copy which hashtags this is a
skill this is not your 22-year-old
[__] niece doing this for your
company this is a massive skill and it's
the most important skill and I think
everybody here is punting it and having
it as their 15th to 80th biggest
priority and I believe from the Utah
Jazz to an entrepreneur out here on day
one the craft of producing 30 40 50 60
ads a day a day 30 40 50 60 a day across
11 platforms targeting different demos
this is for the female fans this is for
the female 32 to 40y Old fans who like
Taylor Swift and go to yoga this is for
55 to 57y old African-American fans who
like Jay-Z like deep
segmentation 30 40 50 segmentations if
you're a B2B SAS business this is for
the CFOs on LinkedIn of Fortune 5000
companies where we're going to make copy
and creative that tells them how much
money they will save if they use our SAS
product cuz they're a CFO and you
[__] CFOs out there you love saving
money who's a CFO Make Some
Noise there's like there's like 10 CFOs
because they wouldn't want to
pay so anyway look obviously you could
see what that six-minute rant or
whatever the [__] I just did this is
important so
so Gary
uh it's interesting because when we
launched gas plus we actually stood up
scg media where we said no we're going
to be a full Media company and we're
going to staff it with practitioners who
are producing the games who are
producing the content this is right like
it or not like it's not the day where
sports teams throw it over the fence to
someone else to handle distribution
that's right because it's the content
creation if we think about those
practitioners you and I have had the
these conversations well if we look at
14e 500 CMOS
yes and I think the wording from you was
something along the lines
of 90% of them will have worked in one
of my media companies in the next 10
years yeah so we're it's a pretty B for
yeah I mean it's probably a hyperbole
but let me tell you where I was going
with this Ryan and I are were
referencing a time we're together maybe
two or three times ago and he's like
what are you up to like why do you have
an agency like feels like you'd be doing
bigger things and I'm like listen I'm
building by by noise how many of you are
familiar with Star
Wars enough good so I said to Ry I said
Ry I'm building my communications Death
Star right I have 2,000 employees around
the globe 300 people in APAC right now
100 people in latam 300 people in Europe
I'm building a Communications Dev star
I'm the emperor right actually right I'm
the
emperor and with my communications Death
Star I can point it at anything I want
so 7 years ago I pointed it at an app we
incubated at Boehner called resi and
that was highly successful and we sold
that to am x 3 years later I pointed my
death star and sent some Stormtroopers
to go work there and I pointed that at
empathy wines the direct consumer wine
brand and we sold that the consolation
right a couple years ago I made a really
big bet and I pointed my death star and
a ton of Storm Troopers and even a
couple of Darth Vaders to something
called vriends which is my Pokemon
Sesame Street intellectual property
Skeletor last night yes big
collaboration Skeletor and skilled
skeleton at be friends so I'm building
this Communications Death Star
anyway just to come back to being Gary
back to being Gary
um I said to R said we're teaching a
totally different skill he's building an
internal shop he's my homie I just heard
that the biggest fear I have is they
know how to make the content but they
don't know the nuances of the
distribution and how to make the content
for the distribution so they may know
how to make great content ESPN the Jazz
everybody there's a lot of talented
storytellers the problem is every
Storyteller that has been trained for
the last 30 years was not trained in
having to think about the
distribution the distribution was just a
screen 30 minutes yeah okay I'm doing a
sitcom I got to tell the story in 22
minutes that was it today there's not a
single time that I post produce video
that I'm recording that I'm not thinking
about how the algorithm works on
LinkedIn what is the features is it a
carousel ad like why am I posting on
Instagram now a RL two post post where
the first one's an image and the second
one's a video instead of what I've been
doing for two straight years which just
a video it's because I'm watching I'm
day trading attention it goes much
further than that with day trading
attention influencer marketing is one of
the greatest opportunities in marketing
today to either get an obnoxious deal
for 100,000 bucks in one or 30
influencers and crush or spend $100,000
on 1 to 30 influencers and get nothing
these are this is a skill of day trading
all of pop culture distribution creative
variables so what I was saying to Ry was
look if we're if I'm right about this
and
ironically there there's a great company
based here that literally literally I
where are they are they might be
backstage literally two a week ago a
employee that worked for me for the last
9 years became the CMO of a company
based in Utah I just met the gentleman
back in they've been working with one of
my agencies that's where they met her so
yes I do believe that a shocking
percentage of Fortune 500 CMOS in 10 to
20 years would have been traded at
Boehner X and I'm really proud of that
and I want that for those employees and
I want that for the marketing World cuz
I believe that marketing today is in a
[__] show I think we're wasting an
obnoxious amount of money and I think we
need to fix it so I think uh I think I
think everyone here did everyone
understand that the day trading
concept okay so that's a takeaway from
silic slopes I'm writing a book on this
right yeah next year it's coming out day
trading attention it's going to
crush you know what actually for the
people that hear that really follow me
it was originally called jab jab jab
left hook it's the followup from a book
that I know a lot of thank you for all
the thank you for Russia that's the
first one that's the first one I will
sign that for that done lock get her up
here now let's sign if you're live on
face let's [__] mix it up here at
silicon slope Summit um go
uh I want to switch ears I think there's
a lot I mean you talked about growing up
I'll never forget you coming over to my
house you meeting my son jet you asked
him what his favorite number was five
and and his name was jet I like almost
kidnapped this kid yeah yeah and and
then you went on to tell this story
that is kind of shaped
your we're doing this yeah we're right
uh This is how we do it this is how we
do it
come let's clap it up for these two
okay what's your name Adam I'm right
what's up hi Ryan hey how are you I'm
good how are
you oh god let's get the little one
first you saved my life from Death back
in
2011 all right when Laura LM put me in
death with her book making millionaires
crush it have saved my life so since
then I've waited to meet you I'm glad we
met and then my son is so inspired can I
take a
picture who's oh there we go go
okay there
goam go sell that in school for 5 cents
yeah my kids school class is actually
here so are they yeah so there look
there they are let's go back there
straight ahead any language you've heard
today um is
condoned well we'll have it exited um
the
the let's go through that because I
think you you explained a story that I
didn't I didn't understand and
you want me to go into it I've never
forgot that so maybe you just noticed
that I put up the number five definitely
the people that follow me have seen this
ah man I don't like getting emotional
about this but this is this is probably
the most important Story of My Life come
to the USA we're super poor it was like
1978 79 it was a really tough economic
climate in the US The Carter years
you've seen the videos if you didn't
grow up in it gas lines it was really
rough the great uncle who's a distant
relative of my fathers who was going to
kind of watch out for us when we came to
America the way that I got out of the
Soviet Union we had to go to Austria for
3 weeks we were in Italy for 3 months
and then we got the proper papers and we
were able to come to America during that
3-month period the great uncle dies so
now we come to America and we're like
you know in a in a spot and so I live in
a studio apartment with eight family
members like like like I am driven by
gratitude I can never get fancy I'm from
the dirt you know and so my father gets
a job as a stock boy in a liquor store
in New Jersey he's literally commuting
from Queens to New Jersey for like two
bucks an hour it's like insane that this
is like 5 minutes ago my dad works his
face off becomes the manager of the
store that lets us move to Edison New
Jersey that's really where I grew up
that's where I was
Americanized literally for the kids
under 30 here you won't understand this
but I went outside to
play
and so you know I went outside and
literally for everyone over 40 or 45 you
know exactly where I'm going in the
beginning of your childhood you go
outside and play and you like look for
people so I'm like walking around town
and like in a distance I'm like wait a
minute there's some kids I you you see
them everywhere fair enough in Jersey
they were everywhere too but like you
just had to find it I found these kids
and they were playing football and I
walked over and these became my best
friends growing up they were playing
football and they're like are you a
football fan and I'm like I'm I'm just
barely getting English down at this
point and they're like well you're
you're you're with us now and they're
like you're a Jets fan and that was I
really wish they said something
else so that was 1982 and now I'm pop
committed I watched this was August
right before school we just moved before
school so I watched the whole season and
the Jets in typical Jets what they've
done to me fashion tricked the [__] out
of me the 1982 Jets went all the way to
the AFC Championship game literally the
game before the Super Bowl I'm like this
is good it took literally 16 more years
to for them to even get that close so
now I'm fully in I'm in I'm in and all
my we're playing football every day with
the Nerf ball every day and my friends
all have a Jets Jersey and I asked my
mom for a Jet's Jersey and we were poor
and like you didn't like we weren't
really like that we were immigrants like
you don't buy a $20 Jersey like money
was for food and maybe clothes you know
and so she said no and unbeknown to me
over the next four or 5 weeks my mom
after she put bed from 10 p.m. on to
midnight started knitting me a Jets
Jersey and on that Jersey was the number
five and that's because 2 years earlier
when I was five I decided five was my
favorite
number I still have that Jets Jersey I
wore it every single day
and the reason I throw up five in every
photo is my mother is my hero my
[Applause]
mother I get a lot of accolades I get a
lot of love and 100% Dad don't be mad at
me but an enormous amount close to 100%
of the reason it happens is the way she
parented me who she is who she was who
she is today and all I'm really doing
for the world is extending what she did
to me to the world and the reason I've
saved that Jersey is when I buy the New
York Jets in the future can happen bro
when I'm going to put that jersey in the
front of the stadium when everybody
walks in I'm literally when I design the
stadium I'm going to design it so that
the majority of people have to walk
through the middle while still getting
everybody to their seats nicely just a
little advice um grab the te first
before you design the new St
Fair through that now but uh real quick
I want to say the punch line I'm going
to put that Jersey in front of everybody
it's going to have a little plaque and
it's going to say from not being able to
buy a Jets Jersey to
buying close your ears kids the whole
[__]
[Applause]
team
listen I'm incredibly proud of you I
love this town honestly I was here last
weekend I've been here several times
since rise really jumped in I got to
tell you I just you know I know we're
wrapping up I'm just so humbled to be
here I adore that would be the word I
use I adore the entrepreneurial Spirit
the community feel the civility that I
see from the airport to the hotel to the
meetings that many people in this town
treat each other with I love being here
I'm so honored to be a part of this I
hope you heard me on the day trading
attention thing for the Practical stuff
I hope you heard the mom story for the
macro stuff [__] the business find your
happiness be nice life life could be so
good if you don't complicate it and I
love you brother and I'm proud of you
and I'm happy to be here first of all I
want to thank you I know you just came
all the way across the country just for
this for these folks so hey if you do
Von here would you guys all
come that's good Bas to
start like we got to do it listen if you
want to give the arena for
free you mean
did again you know these are business
conversations we can have we can do it
public let's do it though let's go bro
give it up for Gary everyone love you
everybody thank
[Music]
you